[Music]
[Applause]
let's go to uh Chris Sims who joins us
now on loan from pro football talk live
hey we haven't spoken to you in a while
here so uh Super Bowl Fallout here now
we're talking about Jalen hurts getting
paid I don't know if you're on the same
page with uh giving him 45 million
dollars but what options do the Eagles
have in a situation like this no you're
right I think you said it right I mean
options are limited and I know I I he
deserves that I do he's you know proven
people like me where I didn't know how
good he could be as a pocket passer or
throw in the football he proved me wrong
I mean it's certainly where I thought it
ended last year we saw tremendous
progress there and of course you know
and and one of the all-time runs there
by a really good football team and then
now they're at a point too where he's
got them is that they got a great team
and they've kind of orchestrated this
offense around his talents so from that
standpoint yeah there's no doubt he
deserves to be paid and uh you know I
gotta I I really I got a lot of respect
for Jalen hurts and some of the things
he he's done in his career to this time
and the adjustments he's made what were
your reservations about him
well yeah just the the
again at the Run game work if they
played a team that was able to slow the
Run game right there was tight window
throws you know making the proper throw
you know putting the ball in a location
that you know made sense for a
quarterback things like that that
quickness of the release the quality of
the football all of those you know were
things I questioned I mean there was a
reason again I know I say these things
and people go oh you're a hater and I
want to go wait but this is why he left
Alabama and went to Oklahoma because
there was those issues and that's why he
was drafted in the second round because
you know I think a lot of people came
away from his Pro Day workouts going
okay it's good but it's not great
um but we've seen the adjustments made
and you know they got a really damn good
team down there in Philadelphia your
thoughts on the Chiefs Victory lap where
they're taking receipts they're calling
out everybody who didn't believe in the
Chiefs yeah well hey they're a special
team they're a chippy bunch in their own
right and you know I think they felt
disrespected with the talk of the
Bangles right the the talk of the Eagles
are going to win the Super Bowl they're
way better oh you lost Tyree kill you're
not going to be the same quarterback my
Holmes or team and all of that so that's
where I don't think Kansas City has got
enough credit is there you know either a
passing team but they're a physical
passing team as we've seen I mean
stopped two of the all-time run teams
we've seen here to win Super Bowls the
last 10 years the 49ers the Shanahan
offense got physical stop the run game
in that one yeah did it again in this
one and you know they they got something
going as far as a young team that I
think is you know only going to get
better
and it's pretty it's complete and really
Dan the thing about that Super Bowl I
mean Mahomes was phenomenal Steve
spagnolo and what he did on the
defensive side of the ball that was an
all-time defensive game plan it really
was it was special uh and some of the
things he did for them to win I know
people are gonna go well you got up 400
yards how special it was if he didn't do
some of the things he did it would have
been 600 yards and 45 minutes of time
and possession so that was a special
game plan from him more likely to get
back to the Super Bowl the Eagles are
the Chiefs
man they're both high up there I mean of
course I'm going to take the Chiefs I
mean the Chiefs to me are a team that
like it's
um to me it's like when they win it's
like hey the pressure's off and let's
just go do this again and they have fun
and they're not it's like not like New
England where maybe they're stressed out
all the time and you know it's Bill
putting the hot poker on on everybody's
butt and all that conversation so yeah
I'll go with them and the Eagles though
that team that roster man they're scary
I mean they they really are that's where
you know there's two things about that
Super Bowl one I mean there's a reason
Fox all the people in the pregame you
saw all them pick the Eagles by seven
ten points right right you saw Greg
Olsen come on The Telecast and tell you
how you talk to people around the League
this is like the roster of rosters that
was an unbelievable moment Kansas City
was not as good as Philadelphia and the
game game plan in my homes the way he
played was amazing and that's where I'm
Amazed by that and then the other one
that I'm Amazed by is that people think
Jalen hurt should be the MVP over
Patrick Mahomes that's where I just go
that's insane I don't understand what
people are saying there he's Chris Sims
pro football talk live co-host with Mike
Florio I said when asked this question
that the Eagles might have a better
chance because the AFC is loaded right
the NFC who are you worrying about the
Niners
right I mean I I hear you that's your
main competition and it and it's not to
discredit the Chiefs it's the the AFC is
loaded the best quarterbacks are in the
AFC and that's why I think it would be
tougher it doesn't mean they can't make
it just yeah I look at the Eagles but I
also look at the Eagles you're going to
lose some guys free agency you're going
to pay hurts all that money right uh is
Kelsey gonna play uh I mean the the
offensive line Lane Johnson like these
guys are getting up there and and so I I
don't think this is a dynasty I think
they got some really good players I I'm
gonna be curious of how long they can
keep them and continue to play and you
lose both of your uh coordinators there
as well right no they got an uphill
battle they're right and you said it all
right I think you unpack those details
correctly you know we've seen the Chiefs
can orchestrate it you know with the
quarterback contract and they know how
to develop young talent and you know and
your point about the AFC and how tough
it is is like totally real Dan I'm with
you I mean that's no clear-cut right or
wrong there yeah I think the AFC we
might be getting into the like mid 80s
early 90s conversation almost where it's
like okay yeah Kansas City's the main
team and then hey the Bengals win one
and then the Bills win one and then hey
it's Kansas City again and then you know
almost like it was with the Niners the
Giants the you know Washington Redskins
at the time yeah the Bears the Cowboys
you kind of knew it was going to be
those type of teams but you know to your
point I'm interested to see what magic
Hallie Roseman can work there in
Philadelphia once again and you know I
just I'm a Believer in that greatness of
the Chiefs football team to think
they'll be back especially with that guy
at quarterback why does Eric B enemy
have to leave the Chiefs to take the
same job with the Commanders
he's like a it's like a it's a gift and
a curse right like yeah it's a gift I
work with Patrick Mahomes and Andy Reed
but nobody gives him credit for it and I
think that's why I think maybe this if
he can go somewhere and man I love the
fit with the Washington commanders I
love the FED because you think about
what they got right Dan Terry McLaurin
Curtis Samuel Jahan Dotson right Antonio
Gibson a running back you know even Sam
Howell he's got a he can throw the Deep
ball and move a little that's a lot of
things Eric B enemy can get people
motion and shifting and going all
different places so uh but I think that
if he did it and went there in a place
like that on his own and had success
people would run out of some of those
excuses they use against them and you
know my other thing is maybe Eric B
enemy has to play the game within the
game a little bit gotta be maybe a
little more of a politician behind the
scenes because I think that's what some
of these guys that are passing them up
are doing maybe and he's old school and
I respect that but that doesn't always
get you a job so that's what you're
hearing
yeah yeah that's what I'm I've always
heard yeah but I I would go to Andy Reed
Chris if I'm let's say I'm going to hire
Eric benemi I want to bring him in first
guy I go to is Andy Reed the second guy
I go to I ask if I can talk to Patrick
Mahomes right and just say can you can
you tell me what Eric does yeah we had
Orlando Brown Jr on yesterday and I said
who calls the place does Eric call the
plays he says I don't know like they
like there's a mystery here that right
it's it's strange I know I know it is
it's weird you know it's weird and I get
and I think they share the duties a
little bit and that's part of it but see
my problem Dan is like nobody cares
about these questions when it's an
offensive coach off the Shanahan staff
or the McVay staff right that's where
they just go well oh he's never called
plays or he just worked there let's give
him the head job but this one all of a
sudden we got 25 questions about it and
that's where I think it doesn't yeah
look right all the time right yeah and I
I think that's fair
um okay a couple of things if you ran
the Bears you're on the clock
what are you doing with the number one
pick
I'm going with defense okay this is this
is where the world's crazy all right I'm
gonna have a little chuckle with you
here right because I was kind of
portrayed as the Justin Fields hater of
the world right when he was coming out
in the draft uh you know I had some
issues throwing the football now I'm the
guy in Chicago or anywhere else going
I'm defending Justin fields and now all
those people that were telling me I was
an idiot and that I only had the job
because of my dad they're going wait
he's not questioned he's got questions
throwing the football he's got quite
we're not sure about him throwing the
football I want to go well no you know
no crap thank you oh but don't apologize
or anything but my thing here would be
the biggest thing Dan is I'm just
Justin Fields has an elite trait that's
really rare I would never trade that
it's not sustainable no it might not be
but I don't know is Bryce young at 5 11
180 pounds sustainable either that's
what I would argue to that right but so
I got to do the math I gotta do this is
a math you know equation I gotta pay
fields in a year and a half
and I gotta pay him a lot of money I can
get I can reset the clock you're not
ready to win anything now
and you can trade him away give you know
send him to Carolina and let him be a
star down there you take your
quarterback you have to entertain that
you may not like it but just because I
got a thousand yard rusher and he's my
quarterback doesn't mean I want to keep
him as my quarterback
I I listen I I hear you there and as
Bryce young rated higher is he graded
higher than just Justin Fields was
coming out the answer is yes right right
yeah probably and I haven't studied
those guys yet so I can't give you a
fair assessment on it yet you know we'll
get there and I'm sure we'll have
conversations and then I I hear the
things you're saying there too and I
don't think you know those are wrong but
see to me this is again it's almost like
the enemy thing we use that against
Justin Fields but I don't hear anyone go
but it's not sustainable with Justin
hurt I mean Jalen hurts it's so it's
okay with him but Justin fields and what
I want to say is put an offensive line
like the bear like the Eagles have and
put two number one Superstar receivers
on the outside and uh oh yeah but but
you don't have that Jayla Jalen hurts
does have the element of I can throw to
Devonte Smith or uh AJ Brown well
they're going to have a ton of money in
Chicago this year I hope those are some
of the things they do right Justin
fields to your point too Dan he needs to
learn to take care of himself I I do
think playing that way is sustainable
you know as long as the quarterback
knows how to protect himself and you
know the other thing is you don't need
to run them 20 times a game you just
have to have that threat of him
available you do have to run him because
they have no offense well he'll that'll
happen but I don't think you have to
call 20 design game you know game Run
game design runs for the quarterback I'm
saying if you call eight to ten he's in
the floor with a hundred yards and those
eight to ten rushes plus the scrambles
that happen and yes I'm hoping that you
know this is why they bit the bullet
last year they they were paying millions
and millions to guys that weren't even
on the team so hopefully they can do
that but back to the main point is
Justin Fields is like like he's an elite
Runner he's an all-time great Runner and
like I would put it up there not just
with the quarterbacks I I would go top
five put the ball in his hands anybody
position in football right now I go
Justin Fields he's in that conversation
and I just wouldn't trade that away then
all right if you run the Jets
what are you doing
oh
well
I mean I I know Aaron Rodgers is of
course the big shiny object that's out
there that would scare me I mean I Aaron
Rodgers at his best is the best option
out there
but what it goes into trading for him
you know the commitment you're gonna get
him from him as far as years
and Dan some of the things you heard me
talk about on the show this year right
you know it was not a great year it was
antsy in the pocket he was unwilling to
pull the trigger and make throws into
Tight Windows so that would scare me a
little it would you know so I I of
course Rogers is probably candidate
number one but then after that I think I
look at Derek Carr to be the next guy I
said you could have Derek Carr you don't
have to trade for him yeah I'm gonna get
him for four years right no drama yeah
or I'm gonna get Aaron Rodgers maybe for
two years maybe I would take Derek Carr
for four yeah
because the Jets are really close like
they're they're a playoff caliber team
in the waiting definitely and but they
might be two years away
from being you know an actual playoff
team you know so that can make a run in
the Super Bowl yeah I hear you yeah so I
would look at that window
Aaron Rodgers coming in I I just don't
want to deal as great as he is I don't
want to deal with that you know one year
to the next I I just can't do it I think
it's fair I that was the number one
thing that would scare me is what you're
saying that okay yeah we trade the farm
we pay him this money we establish
something oh crap we're right back in
the same boat and we need a quarterback
now hopefully that's where maybe a Zach
Wilson could take over and develop we'll
see but either way I I think you're
you're saying some really true football
things there you know to your point too
you get a Derek Carr well that probably
would end the Zach Wilson thing unless
he failed miserably but the other thing
is you know you said it right they're a
young team so you get a Derek Carr you
can man he builds something here for the
future that's sustainable as well I'll
be interested to see what they do
because Roger's car Garoppolo you know I
could see any of that kind of stuff
happening I'll leave you with this do
you think the Packers have already
headed down the road without Aaron
Rodgers
I certainly think they're thinking about
it right and then and have at least a
pre-plan down there and I don't have any
inside info to you know shed light on
that situation but how can they not be
right how could they not be a little
sick of the drama and all the stuff all
the time as well like you just discussed
so uh I gotta think they're kind of
getting their ducks in a row like when
Rogers made the comment two weeks ago
like seems like there's some
conversations about me going on that I'm
not well there has to be like what do
you these teams can't just go where
we'll think about quarterback until he
comes out of the dark room and then
we'll try to they got to start figuring
things out and talking you know behind
the scenes a little bit so I would think
there's some pre-planning Dan have you
gone into a dark room before
no no never okay never only when I go to
sleep I mean that's it I like it dark
then but after that no okay yeah you
just can't okay yeah that's not for me
all right great to talk to you The Man
Dan that's uh Chris Sims pro football
talk live co-host with Mike Florio the
show that precedes ours